[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord here we
back with another attic show uh you know
we as you could tell missed this last
week
we was m.i.a when we we technically did
a show last week but it was just it was
sunday not not wednesday and when
wednesday roll away man i i considered
doing a show when that god of war stuff
got announced but i was just like am i
really going to go on here and talk
about god of war for an hour and a half
i was absolutely not i only want to talk
about god of war for 20 minutes after
time
uh but you know here here we are we're
not a minute late okay we launched at
five o'clock
all right you're gonna have to get off
of me man you got to get off of me so
we're back with another attitude we talk
about the past present future of gaming
got my co-host with me hustling motivate
what you've been playing man what's been
going on oh so what i've been playing
what i've been playing um
nba street vacuum 2 playstation 2
version
appreciate that dirk appreciate that i
also been playing
what is it dev jam fight from new york
which took forever to get to me i've
been playing that as well so i've been
playing that um
y'all catch me on twitch i will be
streaming these on twitch probably
starting monday um started a new job
today kind of all discombobulated
glad i'm here because i kind of just
want to you know just get the stress out
the way man and just kick it with the
homies today but um y'all catch me every
monday tuesday wait monday tuesday
thursday friday on twitch.tv hustle and
motivate i will be playing
all of the classic games because i like
the retro stuff um god of war i guess
we'll talk about it at some point i will
be playing god of war i got the classic
god awards coming in too god of war one
the the ones that jeff you made the part
one japanese how we're gonna describe
them from now on the ones that japanese
don't want them ones that jeffy made i
got them joints coming in too they'll be
here thursday so i got some some special
stuff planned you know it would be cool
if all of you all could join me i know
that you guys don't really do the
youtube the twitch thing so it'll be
cooler for fewer y'all because a few of
y'all have been like hitting the follow
button i've been seeing y'all and i
really appreciate it
put that twitch link in the chat oh yeah
do it in a minute i'll do it in a minute
um outside of that man ain't nothing
going on just
i just been chilling man i've been i
just been handling you know my business
and just i just been here how about you
add it you know what i think dirt i
think that playstation is so dry he over
there playing ps2 games oh man y'all
want to talk about it
hey listen listen i played my most
anticipated game this year which was
shredders revenge i played and beat that
joint so
i'm cool i'm i'm like yeah i'm either
waiting for that and then the last of us
is going to come out a little bit later
on um what september is second i think
so yeah so i'm just waiting on it man
you know i'm just waiting just
letting time pass me by i like the retro
stuff what you want me to do
oh what what you doing dirt man what you
doing i i noticed you got the
the red fall background today yeah i'm
actually hyped for that game man but uh
we're actually talking about it today
yeah yeah it's cool stuff man but you
know i actually been playing a little um
lost judgment you know the um
the judgment game because i actually
bought the game at launch but haven't
played it until now in this you know so
far it's a little slow but it's starting
to get really good and also i've been on
my ps5 man i've been playing a little
eternal little spider-man miles morales
on my playstation premium plus i mean
plus premium
subscription
and so that's about it man i'll be
playing those games and that's it bro
that's all i'll be doing man
like you said it's a slow you know a
little slow gaming news
yeah last couple weeks so we had some
things here and there but for the most
part kind of slow so i'll be playing
games mostly yeah and i i i have been
playing fable anniversary
mm-hmm
yeah they say you're a little low i i
don't think you're low but you know
where my eyes you're long that's why i
was asked i'm like a z-lo on the on the
joint so
about to turn them off just a little bit
see y'all hey another dude come out this
year how about that i forgot i see i saw
i saw better that announcement this
morning before i left oh they they
announced it's coming out this year it's
like october october something uh i
thought that's another game i'm gonna
avoid oh man
damn
dude
man let's be real here nintendo games
are the only reliable thing you could
play on the switch
because
it doesn't feel like the game runs
like a power point because their games
are usually scaled very that cloaked
down like your pokemons your kirbys
like those games don't feel like it
takes power to use
bayonetta is literally gonna feel like a
powerful i hope i'm wrong i'm hoping
that game comes out and it functions
solid 60 frames a second but does does
anyone on this panel actually think that
game's gonna run like that
no
yeah it is what it hopefully does though
hopefully it does yeah but i've been
playing fable anniversary uh yeah i got
about through the halfway through the
game
a good amount and like you know because
i'm about to make more fable content
because that's what people keep asking
me for i'm not a fable content creator
uh you know sometimes i have to make
that very clear by not making fable
content
because i i don't i want to be a variety
youtuber or a variety streamer on twitch
like i don't want to like dig myself in
a hole and then bury my
i don't want to do that so
it's like look like i'm mainly an xbox
content creator that talks about mainly
the games that they that they publish
and you know
fable just happens to be one of them but
i but
it's no denying that i'm a huge fable
fan and you know i'm playing fable fable
one
i'm going through this game and i'm just
realizing
you know lionhead studio was so ahead of
its time and if they would have but i
feel like they were too ambitious to to
a degree and that's what led to their
downfall
you know they were
instead of taking the foundation of
fable
this amazing foundation they had they're
like what can we do that's not in this
house let's make a foundation over there
and i felt like that was the key problem
with fable now i'm not going to say that
you know the game
fable one was perfect
but man i was playing with jack a blade
i was playing and jack of blades popped
up and i and i started thinking
it's been about halfway through the game
and they have not introduced the main
antagonist
when does games do that
yeah like you spend like the whole
beginning of the game
not knowing who you're trying to kill
you know what i'm saying there's no like
at the beginning where you know he just
shows up and kills someone and then it's
like the rest of the game's a revenge
story like it's like the majority of
fable one
feels like you don't know what's going
on and then you find out that this dude
named jack of blades and what's funny is
jacob people don't realize how big
the origins of that character is like
they could theoretically make three
games off of just
the original storyline like there's the
uh there's before the king uh before
albion the old kingdom that's when jack
of blades queen of blades and knight of
blades first appeared and they started
wreaking havoc all across everything
then you got the
the the regular timeline which is what
you're doing now then you have obviously
the post timeline which is like you know
the tech world and stuff and it's just
like you know seeing jack of blades and
seeing this game and you know there's a
real estate market in this game you can
buy
property and put it for rent and stuff
like we're thinking of like a 2 000 like
when did when did fable come out what
was that 2002 2003 oh yeah it was the
original xbox so i'm thinking
how do i sound what's it saying yeah you
found something funny
2004 it was 2004 yeah yeah so like
towards the end of the generation if you
think about it this game came out in
2004
and it had
a solid
combat system which you know it could
obviously improve everything can improve
it had a unique magic system where it
would enhance your combat styles it had
a pretty good story i mean i wouldn't
say it's like the greatest story had an
amazing antagonist which is jack of
blades it had a real estate system which
to this day you don't see in too many
games
it's just it's it's interesting because
that's one one of the key ways you make
money i just i'm playing this and i'm
just like
i hope playground don't mess this up
i think you'll be fine i think you'll be
fine i got a question yeah
is that
the first fable um because it was one of
those fables because they was hailing it
was like the greatest rpg all the time
this is the one that you can make
decisions whether you want to be like a
good person or a bad person that's all i
think that's all yeah
so i'll give you an example all right so
in fable 2
there's scenarios where
you're trying to find the will uh the
hero of will
it's uh subletting garth okay so he got
kidnapped and he's in this prison and
they have him in a special section of
the prison because he's a will user they
have to handle him differently than you
would handle other people because he
could shoot lightning at you so why
wouldn't you handle them differently oh
yeah so uh
well i mean they uh will uses pretty
much magic like they throw fireballs at
you and stuff so
you go there disguised as a guard
because you have to me you have to get
him to escape so
in order to keep your composure and to
keep
what the uh you know it takes 10 years
to get garth out of that prison
and you have to pretend to be the guard
so you have to there's this part where
you have to
uh torture people
uh but you cannot not torture people and
have a good and a good result or you can
you could do certain other things now
there was this one they got a lot of bad
feedback and i can't remember
i might be
off on this one but if i remember
correctly there's this point
where you
they made you choose between because
obviously you have years of your life
and they made you choose between
torturing a kid or you 10 years of your
life
okay
it's a dark game man like you know i i
think fable one's the best because of
jack of blades i always feel like
stories need a good antagonist they need
one
and i felt like jack of blades is just
[ __ ]
like
crazy like jack of blades is pretty much
an individual that has possessed a mask
and if you put his mat like pretty much
like he will possess heroes which is
pretty much people with powers and
he'll put like this this legend out
there he said look if you if you go if
you want power
find my mask
and he'll like pretty much haunt them
and when they find this mask
yeah so it wasn't that it wasn't it was
so it was a regular person that it
wasn't a kid but i do remember
torturing someone i think it was in the
prison i can't remember exactly who you
were torturing but so pretty much like
you um
when you find their mask and you put the
mask on
what happens is
jack's
jack takes over your mind like he takes
over your body
i mean he did offer you more power but
it's him getting the power not you
and and it's cool because like at the
very end of fable one uh spoiler alert
like you you finally chase jack blades
back to like well back to this outside
skirt
and if uh you you defeat him and you're
holding his mask in his hand because you
finally find out that that's the reason
that he's alive because your ancestor
this dude named william killed
uh the queen of blades and and the
knights of blades but they didn't put
their soul until their mask and you're
holding his mask and he's talking to you
through he's like you know you don't
want to destroy my mask if you put it on
you'll be the strongest person to ever
exist
i it gives you the option to put on his
mask and become jack of blades
it's just a good game and it's like
that's what i'm saying like playground
they need they they need to hit this out
of the park like to me
i lost them though
a lot of people
oh yeah it might have been it was
probably that then killing a guard you
were friends with in the prison still
dark yeah it's been so long since i
played two um but you know it's a dark
game man it's a dark i remember there's
right before you go into that tower for
10 years if you give
your um
if you give your
some dude wants you to invest into him
like he's like oh if you invest into me
uh in the future you'll get money so if
you give him money then when you come
out ten years later you get like thirty
thousand dollars like
so it's it's a nice game man it's a nice
guy but anyway we ain't gonna go on to
that because i know you guys want the
smoke man you guys don't want to talk
about fable uh so you know what we have
uh we have a good show for you guys
today we do i'm kind of curious what
what what the uh what everyone wants to
talk about first you know
we got obviously
let me click this we got e3 returning
which uh i do want to point out uh i
told you so
uh i i've been saying for a while that
e3 was going to be here and and people
would sit there telling me i was i was
delusional
you know there's no way e3's well trust
me the only people that don't want e3 is
playstation fanboys
can i'm not a playstation okay
then why don't you want e3 well uh
hustle we'll start with the e3 topic why
don't you want e3 hustle
it is a shell of its former self like
why is it a shell of its former self
hustle
let me let me speak look how many
companies don't pull it out nintendo was
the pioneers of this here nintendo said
now we out don't worry nintendo's still
there continue uh okay we don't get a
press conference this is what i mean by
that also hey listen man they what the
last time we heard about e3 right and i
want y'all to correct me if i'm wrong i
was trying to introduce like lebron
james and i had this whole celebrity
sector that ain't what e3 is now i don't
remember that
no no they definitely had a report i
remember doing a video on it they
definitely had a report saying that e3
was going to get a massive overhaul
because it was just so it was so dead
and it was so dry and it was so boring
so they were going to try to get like
different celebrities
you know and on the say fun so to speak
and i definitely remember that um
it's over when it's over it's over and
here's the thing jeff kelly didn't kill
e3 e3 killed e3 um
yeah yeah cause we can get to jeff
kelly's stuff in a minute man the the
first summer game has not officially
ended i just want to say for the record
it's like i watched a lot of wrestling
so it's like when somebody's in the
royal rumble they don't get eliminated
they're just under the ring
that's
the very first edition of the summer's
game fest it's not over yet it's
officially not over and i'm being a jerk
or whatever but jeff will be i um
and shout out to jeff throwing shade
every chance he get at every chance he
get bro you know he's throwing shots
boy you in the industry jeff you got to
do better i'm not enough but but it's
over like it's like i feel like the
majesty is of that is gone now attic
you've gone and dirt i don't know if
you've gone to ep i've never gone though
you've been there and you and the
lawyers have been there man it's not the
same and i want you to and i want you to
feel free to correct me if i'm wrong but
hey look man i feel like it's it is it's
over and done with whatever was left of
it
like because they keep having it out in
la i think they only had it on atlanta i
think one time before that if they
changed locations because i remember
being on press starting we had this
conversation what i would do to change
e3 because it was so the attendance was
so dry and so boring like i would put it
in different cities and i would adopt
the actual theme of the city that you're
in like for instance i'm in dc right i'm
from dc so
it'd be a lot of go-go music a lot of
chicken wings like mambo sauce it's what
we eat out here right or if you're in
maryland you know the state that i live
in it'd be like seafood related it'd be
it would it would have been looking like
baltimore or something there's there's a
they're trying to do a lot to e3 to
actually bring it back and make it
relevant again and that's why i said
that they're trying to add the
celebrities and i find that article i
think it was by kotaku i found that
article i'm definitely going to link
y'all with it because i know i ain't
talking other side of my necks i know
the video on that as well but this
it's bad man it's bad not only do i not
want to see e3 but
look if you want to do an in-person
event
like i feel like pax is better than e3
easier than jumped over the trump man in
my opinion my humble opinion
you know the people that
control
packs they're the ones that's going to
do an e3 now well all right
well we'll look at me not knowing and
just putting it out to the universe and
you see how i was giving back to me
don't you just see what i'm saying would
you say what i'm saying right like i
feel like you set me up there
huh
i wasn't even trying i promise i
wouldn't but no that's that's the thing
like we can everybody can see that
they've lost their way in terms of
what it used to be
in terms of how big it was yeah i mean
in terms of how big it was and then
ain't like that big no more they they
know everybody know it everybody know it
said hold on okay it was kotaku it was
one of them damn outlets don't don't do
i said kotaku just because whatever it
was one of the major outlets it might
have been ign who knows oh igm they're
another one by the way you know trying
to get e3 about the paint by the way
because they got their own summer of
these things called summer and gaming
they got their own thing they got their
own thing too and this it's not bad
you know yeah they they be doing
anything but e3 it ain't they need it no
more playboy it's over
how do i know exactly where people are
gonna lean for
you know dirt man save us save us of
logical oh man okay i'm excited i'm
gonna say this
more game shows the better right now
first off i'm going to say this e3 will
most likely never be what it was
um do due to you know sony not being
there
you know excuse me ea most likely won't
be there ubisoft for whoever i'm not
sure if those people will be there but i
know sony won't be there but i will say
this
it probably won't be as great as it was
but i'm happy that it's back
because we know xbox is going to be
there like going back think about what
e3 used to be some of the moments the
live crowd is the thing i'm most looking
forward to right because we know you
know last year we had the um
the game awards show and that's fine
but that's not
us
it was media you know with other people
there there's some celebrities there but
e3 would be us the hardcore gamers
that's getting hyped for announcements
you know
the cheering the you know the
everybody's rejoicing just because they
announced something that you guys want
to see help people cheer for stuff
that's not even really that exciting
you think about some of the stuff that
happened in the past
you know like in 2013 where ps like
playstation is totally just
smack the [ __ ] i mean i'm sorry i
smacked the hell out of xbox
from like 2015 when i feel spirits
announce backwards compatibility and all
of these things is what i'm looking
forward to um so yes it's e3 what it was
in the past no but willie
like is it possible it can still be
great absolutely it's possible it can
still be great like we know there's
competition now back in the day there
wasn't any competition it was just e3
week everybody was there
us
gamers we loved every minute of it but
now you know we have jeff uh keeley you
know his summer game fest and everything
so
the thing that to really pay attention
to is
who's going to go back to e3 and who's
going to show off their stuff at summer
game fest apparently not hustle
go ahead
real quick put a poll in the chat please
for
do you do we think e3 is needed it's for
the poll
and i just want to say one thing paul
you guys know to vote for what addict
says
when i put this poll in i want you guys
to know
you vote you vote yes
so you you you want me to put um
is e3 what
this is e3 uh is e3 dead maybe that's
that might be too hard to verbiage
y'all want e3 and 20 23. absolutely go
to e3 and 20 yeah there you go yeah yeah
absolutely man i mean it's like it's
it's the big game event for it's like
over the years it seemed like maybe the
game awards has become that you know the
big show where they announced new stuff
xbox has their own show playstation has
their own show but e3 is this something
that i mean even when we're talking
about xbox show we were still saying
xbox e3 you know it was just what it was
and um
i'm excited to see it back will it work
i don't know but i think you know i
think
it has the potential to be still be
pretty strong man
i think the biggest thing
that i will say about e3
people have this misconception with e3
is e3 is not the conferences e3 is after
the conferences if anything
most of the conference is already done
before e3 even takes off e3 is normally
the tuesday wednesday thursday and
friday after all the conferences have
went maybe it's wednesday thursday and
friday i can't remember um you know part
of the issue i think is
esa started valuing money over they
value the event itself now obviously
people want to get paid but there is a
there is give and take when it comes to
monetization value uh they cared more
about
covering up the aspects of people like
playstation leaving was
they they kept more about covering that
money back then they cared about the you
know the publishers themselves coming
the developers themselves coming the
the median influencers and streamers
coming to cover this stuff like look
i'm not saying that you can't have
consumers at an event like that but you
do need a lot of
prep time for the people doing it for a
living or people doing it for a business
you know
king likes to be very bougie when it
comes to this and i agree with certain
aspects that he has and i disagree with
certain aspects uh we need
more time that's just for influencers
media streamers
because i do feel like
a lot of their livelihood is is
depending on this coverage
so i do i do would like for them to have
like a whole day exclusive to media
influencers i don't want none of this
media gets a day
everyone just that tuesday
or monday depending if it's tuesday
through third just have that whole
monday dedicated to nothing but media
uh media influencer streamers like i
said i feel like a lot of people would
be okay with that because you can get
the bulk of your of your work done in
that day
if you're not ruffled around because
you guys ever been there but it's
crowded especially when they let the
consumers in it's crowded i i believe it
and i know but king is right though like
if y'all there to work and put the work
in then then by all means like be there
to put the record i never understood why
you guys didn't have like a separate i
mean media didn't have like a separate
like
three days
before everybody else or maybe or maybe
even after whatever i'm just surprised i
didn't really have unless i'm wrong here
i'm surprised you just didn't have your
own time the way you're not interacting
and mingling with the people because i
mean it's not a meet and greet like
y'all really there to put working for
the site like level one like yeah i mean
like weapon will whoever right they're
there to do work for for the
separate places there so i never really
understood that but i guess because you
know you got i guess you got to run out
of venue and when you rent the venue out
you got to do it for
have a long you know you're allocated
for but you said one day is one day
enough to get everything like it's not
but here's the thing like that where i
don't agree with king is king be acting
like the media sits in these long lines
they don't
like for the most part they got their
own appointments you know how it goes
when your media and you go or have any
type of media badge you know you need to
get a content creator badge or a media
badge because they do what's funny is
this industry likes to say they're the
same thing but they're not like there's
been incidences
where i haven't been able to get a
review code as a media i mean as as an
influencer but if i ask through the
website that i magically get it like
dying light
i don't i don't agree with that because
i feel like
i don't like
timed gate sensitive information unless
the company paid for it like ign they
get a lot of firsts like i don't agree
with that like if they paid for that
that's one thing but it's just like
people that
that grinded to get that type of
coverage
why are you time gating when people can
open stuff like for instance there'll be
times where media
and influencers have different ndas
and i don't understand that really wow
yeah there's been a few of them um i
know for a fact
the dying light 2 was one of them where
if i remember correctly it might not
have been dying like two uh because i i
look at so many ndas these days but
i remember if it was dying like one
a game last year or this year
it was pretty much like the media got to
post their their coverage the whole day
before everyone else
and it's just like to me
i don't agree with that look if you have
to grind your way to that
to that to that level
i don't think you should have a waiting
list if you're not media it's like
in a lot of ways i think you guys can
agree influencers are actually pushing
more
units out for for these companies than
anyone it's not these other companies
like people are like sure me i would say
ign gets to a lot more people i will say
that but for the most part rg just they
they write stuff they push it out there
there's no energy behind it you know i i
do feel like for a podcast you you need
a good mixture
of informative entertainment it needs to
be a good mixture because you got to
keep people's engagement keep people's
attention span but you also got to tell
them what they need to know and i and
i've always felt like ign
they're completely informative i don't
feel like there's a lot of character in
a lot of their podcasts you know what
i'm saying it just feels like they just
sit around and they talk about stuff and
i feel like the only reason that we
haven't needed competition in that in
that direction is because
of that reach because you can get the
the ig in first because you know
gamespot can get this you know uh ga uh
game informer can get that and it's just
like
that's why i get really annoyed when i
see these companies when you see
some of these companies being ingenuine
and these companies like microsoft and
them still work with them because it's
just like you're feeding the beast at
that point like to me it's like if a
company
even if it's ign
if that's not who i'm thinking like if a
company is being ingenuous
you mean disingenuous disingenuous they
have my disingenuous these companies
need to cut them off at least for a
short amount of time because when you
start doing that you start holding
accountability to some of these
companies that are doing stuff out of
the ordinary like kutaku there's no
reason why they get anything in this
gaming industry on the uh on the
on the the industry-wise
they're constantly riling up council war
stuff they're constantly trying to start
converging with everything known to man
and somehow they still get review codes
you know what i'm saying you know i
don't you know i don't because it's the
traffic it's the traffic yeah it's yeah
i can do something today i can go viral
on something today and
hell i i put out a little clip about
nzxt and they can put it back out it
don't matter as long as i can bring
traffic to whatever like
oh i'm gonna be careful saying that it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter whether
it's good bad or negative whether it's
positive or negative that attention is
that attention so that it does help and
i don't want to sound like no hater
either man but you know that are a
couple you know a couple of instances
that i've seen the way i'm like yo come
on here's the thing and i get it that's
why i'm saying the traffic thing
is crazy to me because you're willing to
let a lot of these companies
you know talk there's one thing getting
criticism there's another thing
click-baiting your article to make a
company look bad
and to me if you're feeding this beast
and letting these people do this they're
going to continue to do it and it's
never going to get addressed and that's
why i was saying that like i don't
understand
at this point streamers and influencers
probably sell more games and more
product than media ever will
and i still feel like the media is
getting treated way more royalty than
the rest you know what i'm saying and i
get it like they
in a lot of like ign they're
professional i i would never say
kutaku's professional but you know
i would say not like the whole company
but there are people in kotaku that are
professionals they just they're there
because that's that's their job but it's
just like when it comes to media
i do feel like we we need more of a
balanced slate like you know besides
like ig and first because i feel like
that's a lot more relationships or
strictly money uh cash flowing than
anything else so i can understand that
but it's just like when you have these
incidences where these games have these
ndas like i said where it's like a whole
day to the media first like to me
that's disingenuous
like to me
you're trying to give certain outlets
that you feel like you can control over
random
content creators that you don't feel
like you control and you're trying to
paint the narrative to your direction
and but that's just my opinion
so so was the commercial by the sound of
it if it's just paid advertisement at
that point then this we can just say
what it is it's a commercial at that
point that's not that's not hate it's
just that is what it is hey listen man
i've seen maximilian get sponsored by
like ubisoft to play
some i forget what the name of that game
was but he was playing some game and had
like a free weekend that's sometimes
that's the best promotion man but but
you're right though sometimes you gotta
you gotta put whatever nerd if i'm
paying for something i'm gonna put the
best narrative out there it may sound
disingenuous but it just is what it is
like nah i was like hey i got this thing
it might be a little bit buggy but i
know the child y'all gonna have the kid
gloves going for it and that's just what
it is also shout out to podcasts unlock
man that's my favorite uh podcast over
there ign
literally my favorite podcast and i'm
not even like xbox here like that but
that podcast is really good and when it
comes to e3 it's like i said people just
see the conferences that's all people
don't see what's going on behind closed
doors and i think the reason that even
if e3 died a phoenix would have a
phoenix would have rose up and something
would have took its place
because
huh
yeah i'm just saying i'm ingrained i'm a
great because you
need a
an event where everyone climbles too
and that the reason that the industry
wants this is because notice that
ea
pulled out of e3 but or they're close to
it
and they're probably about 10 miles away
from the actual the actual coliseum
right there's a reason they did that
there's a reason that they didn't go in
florida or texas or new york because
they know
that even though they're not part of e3
they want to be part of e3 they should
want to pay the e3 price right they want
to be near the coliseums because
at that year what's the number one thing
that happens when e3 happens all the
media are there all the content creators
are there all the streamers are there
all the public publishers are there uh
you can have business meetings you can
have brand meetings you can have
sponsorship meetings and you can do
probably
a day's worth
of networking and working at deals than
you could do all year long combined
in that one day because you're able to
because there's no oh what's the day
that works good for you oh okay
let's everybody's there yeah it's like
all it is is meet me at that hotel
beside the starbucks like
i sound like a drug like that yeah
you said it like that like
that's why even though people like to
talk a lot of snap about
e3
it's still important because
maybe not on the consumer side and
people say well xbox is able to do this
playstation's able to do that nintendo's
able to do this
i get that
but at the end of the day i think all of
them value
having everyone under one roof over
everything else and it's like i said i'm
not gonna say that e3 is essential but
an event in america is essential because
that's what this pretty much is it's the
american
conference uh that the majority of the
industry is at well just like tokyo game
shows japan's you know uh the gamescom
is
germany germany
but it's still the whole continent
pretty much people gravitate towards
that and you know it's
it's interesting that uh the people who
make
is is doing this i'm kind of curious
we don't know what e3 under pax's people
gonna look like yeah that's that's the
question for all we know we think
they're gonna bring it back exactly like
e3 and then they throw a wrench in our
plan they're like we're inviting all the
people
so i had to get you've been in the packs
before correct
twice well can you yeah can you okay so
out of the two times that you went can
you tell us what that experience is like
because you can't because you could be
foreshadowing into what it what e3 could
be turning packs
i haven't been to e3 we haven't been to
e3 iops probably tripled it's
it's uh growth since then
we haven't been to e3 with
viewership
and growth wise to be able to like have
significant
interviews and stuff you know what i'm
saying like
we haven't been there to the point where
we can actually talk to some of these
developers
and talk to especially you know
sponsorships uh brand deals stuff like
that we're probably still not there but
we're
last time we went we had 2 000 like
subscribers or something like that we
got oh well we got like 13 000 now
and we keep we we gain a little bit
every month so you know by then we'll
probably be at like 15 000.
so it's just like we haven't been to an
e3 where it's actually relevant to us in
terms of you know us as a brand now
e3 is good if you just want to go there
you want to be around people you want a
social network you want to go to the fan
fest e3 is good for that i feel like pax
some of our most profitable videos and
some of our most popping videos all came
from packs all of them
and that's because i feel like
e3 is the majority of the big players
big indie developers big indie
publishers you know xbox microsoft even
sony to a point you know what's funny
sony might act like they're not there
but they got people there having
meetings with people
yeah i'm almost sure but business is
still getting handled i'm almost sure
i'm sure
so i'm just i would say i enjoy pax more
because
you can actually talk to the devs you
just feel a lot more passionate packs i
feel like
e3 is more business
you know you get you can get we've
gotten a lot of business opportunities
at e3 but
a lot of these people they don't care
you know they care about raw numbers and
most of them don't even look at that
they're like let me see your deck and
it's pretty much like all your analytics
all your numbers and they look at your
your subscriber count they don't even
care about you know you get a thousand
plus live viewers they don't even look
at that
oh you you don't have you don't have a
hundred thousand uh subscribers so come
back to us when you're taller
that that's how a lot of these people
handle this and you know obviously
there's ways that you can get around
that and one of the is social networking
you know if we didn't go to these events
we probably never would have got like
jason ronald on iop or a lot of these
other developers you know
we we was able to bridge the gap a
little bit because we were going out
there social networking yeah yeah and i
think you hit the block you want to and
that you had told me that um told me
that as well behind the scenes he was
like yo in order to get seems like yo
that the sub counts matter but then
again they kind of don't it was like for
real like people just want to see you
so you know
as long as you're professional a lot of
it will work out in your favor when it
comes to the coverage
you can get away from numbers as long as
you meet people the right people can get
you in the right things you can get
review codes you can get coverage you
can get exclusive interviews
but what i have noticed if you want
brand deals and sponsorships you
definitely need numbers for that yeah
they're not gonna give too
hell about anything else but what could
you potentially sell to me
uh so which could you put yourself for
me so it is what i hope e3 i hope it
comes back and you know i hope everyone
comes even sony the good thing is
the people who make packs have a good
relationship with sony
so maybe they could convince them to
come back because i do feel like
the esa
failed us in terms of e3 because they
felt like
they were bigger than the industry at
one at that point
uh they
there was no more communicating with
sony there was no more middle grounds
from sony it was oh
you don't want to you don't want to rock
with this then bounce and sony picked up
the ball and they walked away with it
yeah he did
sorry someone sent me something
so
that that's all it really was like is
that you guys got any thoughts like
are you guys considering going to e3 in
the future if it does come back i am i'm
definitely considering going next year
actually so i'll probably need to make
make the proper arrangements for for it
soon um yeah i'm definitely considering
it bro
no it's something i always wanted to do
so i think i'm at the point where i can
you know
try to go out there and meet people and
actually be there for a live xbox
conference in person
bobby fire so yeah i'm definitely
looking forward to it
what about you hustle
well
if i'm going with lp of course you know
i would love to you know kick it with
y'all
but honestly if i was going out there
just as like a content creator
considering what i'm about to do and how
much i'm streaming and everything i
don't think that would be the event for
me something like twitchcon would be the
event for me though but yeah so e3
probably not so much but like twitchcon
yeah something like that you know
then i'm there and that's even if they
do they choose to do that but not
probably not like i said if i'm kicking
it with with y'all or from like you know
because we got we know a ton of people
around here who make the content and
stuff like that
if i'm kicking them one of y'all sure
but it wasn't like that was never on my
bucket list even when i started youtube
and all that like it would be cool to
see like you guys and like weapon where
i remember bg him went out and he had
the little camera that was cool to see
but it was like that was never like a
goal of mine does that make sense it was
never like the biggest
like goal that was never the biggest
thing for me
what are you guys considering maybe
going to um
going to pax east next year
where is pax at pax essex
and i pull up to join us for money right
hey yeah it's literally just hey that's
because that's a drive up it's like what
a six-hour drive i think if if that it's
like it's just a train
oh really did trains go up there from
well you know i'm in maryland so i mean
as long as there's a train station
probably
10 minutes from the convention center
like it's that close like
that that's what calling them do now
they take trying the train
convention center in dc because we got a
lot of new conventions boston
massachusetts all right well i mean
ain't nothing to me
ain't nothing to me man i mean because
like the reason i tell you to take the
train is because you're going to want to
uber a lot up there because if you don't
uber you're gonna be paying parking
passes for everything fifty dollars
twenty dollars thirty dollars
uh you you wanna be able to just tell
someone drop me off here
and i'm an uber out looks
right
all right well look i'll take that into
consideration all right ain't nothing
for me to
next year
we ain't doing the compound next year at
pax like we we do in hotels next year at
massachusetts because
it's just
we've all like unless the people always
want to do stuff with us but it's got to
the point where we didn't have the ideal
compound like this year at
pax so we just like we we hoteling it up
because it
we most of the time we got to draw like
we got to do an uber like 10 15 20
minutes away and
in massachusetts that gets expensive so
you do that every day going in back
and then you do the foods like at that
point paying the uber and paying the the
via uh the bnb like you might as well
get a hotel
so we're just
we're going to book a hotel
i can imagine and there's a hotel right
beside the convention center
oh okay
it's going to be it's it's gonna be a
little pricey but the the beauty of it
is
you know
you deter you determine
how much you want to spend if you don't
want to go there for the whole week and
just go for a night you know what i'm
saying so
it's just i do feel like
e3 is fun but you need to go to pax too
pax is a really fun thing and i think
it's more it's more of the consumer than
than the professional like you know a
lot of these indie developers like
because that's what pax is there's a lot
of indies uh there obviously does you
know these big publishers do go but it's
a lot of indies but
a lot of the time every year indies is
highlights everything else and you know
you see the passion that these people
have most of the time
we take
we take ilp shirts
and
if we if we really feel the person
that's showing us their game we give
them a shirt
because you know
at that point it's just like dude we we
mess with this game and you know we did
that last year i don't think we did it
this year but uh we're probably gonna do
it next year a lot of stuff was just
weird this year because of the pandemic
you know how
we didn't know if it was going to be
there if it wasn't going to be there
uh you know hopefully next year it will
be a lot better i'm hoping that
pax because here's the thing like pax is
probably going to be early or a little
bit earlier because they're doing e32
so
we're gonna have to travel two times in
probably six months
and you know cog always likes going to
destinycon
so i think i'm gonna go to that next
year too that's in the houston right
and then in texas it's in florida oh
okay
to uh um
florida tampa tampa florida that's where
i'm probably thinking about quakecon i
think that's the one that's in houston
by the way
all right so let's let's okay okay we're
going to give hustle the floor for a
second all right halo infinite is back
in the news oh man
and uh
last sunday you know the chat came at
you a little bit they roasted you you
know they
they they they got a good shade
of cooking on you you know i felt like
at that point people could have just bit
straight into you man because you was
that cook that that that roll so i'm
gonna give you the floor man let let you
uh let you throw your i told you so's on
this halo infinite apparently
the story's been delayed just like
everything gets delayed on hey let's fit
it i feel like we never get good news
for halo and it was funny is my brother
was playing it earlier and it's still
fun
it's just you can have the best combat
in the world
but no one knows about it there's
nothing to do with it it's not going to
matter
so
hustle yeah the floor is yours
well you know first and foremost i want
to thank everybody for interacting with
me in the chat i mean you know y'all
really thought y'all had one up on me
listen man
listen all i know is this
day want 250 000 people on that stream
they were saying the king is back just
that in the fight
real quick also i'm sorry i didn't see
this
i didn't see the super chats
let me get this real quick before you go
on this long drawn out rant of yours we
got to fight all those super chat from
alvin yo lord addict beat dishonored for
the first time last week and you're
right it's a masterpiece 11 out of 10.
still like
death loot but dishonored is go yeah
dishonor is way better than death
death loop is an amazing game and i
liked it uh regardless what uh you know
people like maddie phil maddie don't
like it i feel like it does everything
that this that
that arcane is good for and that's why
red fallen a little bit drawn back from
because i'm a huge fan of death loop of
of uh dishonored and i wanted something
like that it's it's like definitely got
a lot of hate for me originally because
it wasn't dishonored
and that that's that's kind of like i
think what subconsciously i'm doing the
red fall it's not dishonored and it's
got arcane's name on it i don't like it
but uh we'll see continue hustle good
teaching hey i won't even be too long
with it i never said hello infinite was
a bad game first and foremost
they got management issues but you did
say it was dead
oh for sure for sure this isn't this you
know nintendo would never happen keep in
mind the kids kids move dead
live show how long it took time
with his badass he he did the whole best
buddies he did the whole thing yeah that
was cute that was cute all i'm saying is
this all i'm saying is this
your king has failed you and listen and
i don't take pleasure in saying that
attic wanted to give me the floor i
didn't want to take the floors i just
saw it like i didn't want to sing that
day i was chilling i wanted to sit back
and relax and chill
i don't care about halo infinite i can't
if you guys have fun with it
you know it's cool have fun with it it
sucks that you know this it was a beta
that was supposed to come out this month
and it sucks that that was delayed it
sucks that they want to turn a season
into six months
it's it's absolutely like horrible what
they're doing to their fan base right
now but it's not cool it's not cool i
know i was talking talking about you
know whatever i was talking but i don't
want to see y'all like that man
look because why y'all doing that why
why y'all playing you know the one game
i'll play whatever i'll play whatever
and be fine like i'm i promise some
gucci i i promise i'm gucci mane i'm
gucci mane with the trouble so gucci
mane straight power i'm fine i feel bad
for y'all also hey okay
hold on hold on i got a little bit more
smoke i got a little bit more smoke a
lot of y'all
maybe some of y'all in the chat but i'll
be saying a few of y'all on that check
game pass yay
right cool i like game pass too i'm
playing actually playing rainbow six
siege on game pass cool game i never
thought you know i never thought that i
would play rainbow six seasons it's cool
it's fun
turtles and time shredders oh excuse me
teenage mutant ninja turtles shredders
revenge was only beaten by 10 percent of
xbox gamers what come on
come on
percentages percentages more people
played it because of game pad hold on
hold on
don't go there hold up dirt dirt let it
finish before we cook him let him finish
before we go
shut up dirk shut up i don't care if
it's a two-hour game
it's a good game that's that's another
good game that y'all y'all be begging
for games to come to game pass how come
that like
bro that shouldn't be a rare thing that
people beat that game that's all i'm
saying that's all i want to say about
that as far as the halo thing i'm sorry
y'all i'm sorry that and i actually i'm
sorry that i was kind of writing it
stuff is getting delayed because that's
not cool for the fan base man halo
anthony is a fun game
but
you know
we obviously see that there are
management issues there like it ain't
there ain't no fans or buts about that
listen nobody will let this happen with
uncharted or the last of us regardless
of what people might think about it on
the sony yet they wouldn't let this
happen to mario and nintendo regardless
of what people might think about
nintendo's online infrastructure and it
shouldn't be happening this should not
be happening until you know the the top
of the heat the you know this is this
that's the top of the charts over there
that's that's number one that's the
number one it should not be happening
but
no i brought up the turtles and um the
shredders revenge thing dirk only
because you know that's my most
anticipated game of this year and it's
dope it's so dope
can y'all play and look i know that i
know they ain't fixed the bugs yet but
the bugs look i ain't co-signing it but
they ain't that bad
you know what since y'all can't play
listen listen since y'all can't play the
story mode
i shouldn't laugh so i can't play the
story mode in the halloween how about we
all play turtles uh shredders revenge
how about we do that
okay okay okay now whatever you want to
say i don't really care yeah you do what
y'all do man get him dirt get him
see these playstation fanboys they were
wrong no only 12 of people beat beat uh
teenage mutant ninja turtles you know
why the percentage is lower than on
playstation
way more people played it because of
game pass percentages
it could be 12 but it can still like the
number could be more people beat it on
xbox than playstation because more
people played it
because xbox game pass
now you said was just a two-hour game
well i don't know people personal
business they might not have the time to
finish and this and like what you're
saying is actually a few weeks ago
actually
it was right when the game released that
was three weeks ago now yeah i know but
i kind of went here one of the weeks i
remember people said the same thing
about halo infinite when they released
they was oh look at this all these bots
and nobody finished the game but then
they forgot to say that
they included all of the free to play
people
that played the game
oh only two only 10 percent beat the
campaign but how many people played the
game the percentages it's about
percentages bro so you can't really run
with that because you know
[Music]
like okay you're on top of uh like
people could say no i like about it say
yo man it's 120 million ps4 but but the
last one but the last of us two only
sold 10 million
right
well like like what's y'all come back
well
what oh well what what what like what's
y'all come back what's your fault
i'm not i'm not no party so i
percentages
so you brought it up i didn't bring it
up i didn't bring it out you brought it
up i brought it up not even to the whole
xbox families i brought it up to the
people who just be camping for you know
for good games who want to have good
games which you should you're paying
customers you should want to have good
games now you have a good game and if i
were y'all if i were y'all i would just
promote this very good game unless
you're some time for now it ain't even
that no for real so i would promote this
very good game if i were them
the topic was halo infinite and you
brought up teenage mutant ninja turtles
i i did because i did because you know
i'm a few weeks later man i wanted to
bring it up that's my most fancy play
the game this year
all i'm saying is you know i wanted i
wanted to take some time even if it was
in the kind of a slanderous way to
promote that game i really want more
people to play that it was definitely
slime juice i know i know but whatever
i'm going to try but try to entertain
them a little bit but no no but um but
as far as the halo thing man it you know
edgar i know you're going to get your
balls off in a minute it sucks it
absolutely is it absolutely sucks i
don't i don't take pleasure in in saying
i was right about this i feel like you
do a little bit i feel like you know i
really don't know
i really don't i really don't man listen
i promise you though if you think about
halo infinite i'm going to be honest um
there's there's
i don't know what happened with this
game now first of all let me say this i
love the game the game actually released
in a polished state it was definitely
missing content but the game itself
released in a polished state i enjoyed
the campaign i enjoyed the multiplayer
but isn't missing content absolutely and
here we are several months later the
content still isn't hitting like some
people wanted to hit
um you know there's still a lot of games
being played on the xbox side you know i
know i've been playing this past weekend
we had a ball
you know we were playing hello infinite
but there's definitely some type of
management issues there something's
going on no studio is perfect
regardless of what people wanted to see
like no studio is perfect and 343
definitely has their issues
um
i just saw a tweet that the co-op
excuse me campaign is um
set to drop later this week they're
going to stream it tomorrow
so hopefully that
that's coming soon i'm assuming it's
coming soon
so it just seemed like to me
i'm not gonna like fanboy or damage
control
but it seems like something happened
with development on halo infinite they
just got behind man we heard that um
they they canceled 60 percent of the of
the game of the campaign
and and i had to reboot it i had to take
out stuff i'm not sure but it's clear
that
something went wrong with the game
during the development process
um so to see that the game actually
released and a polished state is
actually pretty pretty good you know but
yes i know the seasons are not like the
six months
it's it's definitely a little bit too
long and uh hopefully they can figure
this thing out man that is insane
that's that's wild that's a
that's that's how they can figure it out
man because i mean i i do think the game
play is it's really good on the game man
i like the campaign i thought the story
was good you know yes we did want a
little bit more biomes biomes but
i think the game players there you know
they just got a i don't know there's got
to catch up man stop somehow catch up
it's like i said last week on iop and i
know you know people were going at me
all added to you know this about
halo and for the data about halo
infinite i want halo infinite to succeed
and i wasn't even saying that like
bonnie ross doesn't deserve to be there
it's just like
it could doesn't matter who it is
you need to show me results
or i kind of want people in there that's
going to show me results
now i will say it's like i said since
the pandemic i'm willing to give them to
like the end of 2023 because regardless
what people say they got to give us
content obviously
but you know for the like the battle
royale like huge sets of stuff
i do feel like
two years to catch up from all that
nonsense that the pandemic got to them
all the change in leadership in terms of
like the leads you know if they don't
have something solid and you don't see
like a lot of success with halo infinite
by the end of next year there's
something really wrong and at that point
who you more mad at are you mad at
addict for just wanting the game to be
better or are you mad at people who are
enabling this behavior and continuing
this long hallway of halo seem to never
get fake halo could be i think that's
fair adam would you say that's fair
halo could be
one of the best games on the market
it's got some of the most solid gameplay
on the market
it's never going to be a a fortnight and
i think we need to stop trying to act
like it's going to be a fortnight the
only thing that can be a fortnight is
other battle royale games
other child friendly kid friendly
cartoony looking games too because that
is a bigger audience
you know i know people
that they're 12 13 year olds they all
play fortnite you're never going to get
that with halo sure you're going to get
some people to play halo that's those
age groups
and they're all free to play and that's
the good thing that helps
hey add it but can they get the war zone
audience though
they can
but you're going to have
this battle royale need to hit it needs
to hit hard because
i agree i agree and the way it's looking
it's going to be
the way it's looking it's going to be
its own app it's not going to be part of
what's going on now it's going to be its
own app so i'm kind of curious how this
works
i i just want i just want halo to do
well i want halo to be where it needs to
be i want faye will to be where it needs
to be because i truly feel like
microsoft
if they get their act together
and you know people like to say
mismanagement i don't personally feel
like microsoft has mismanagement issues
some of microsoft studios have
mismanagement student issues
people like to give this this broad
act like it's microsoft as a whole when
you have 30 plus studios and i'm
counting the activision deal because
it's probably going through
you're going to have some that just
don't do what they supposed to
it's just
it's just how it is
there's not the same energy when people
look at ben's studio that didn't hit
right
where's the people that were looking at
you know recore how it not record return
on how it came out busted
giving
playstations being shut down
what was that energy wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait see that's why i gotta
stop you at people definitely had smoke
for return and they was like yo you
gotta cause i got return everything you
gotta keep it in on rest mode absolutely
not
man look i will cut that joint off and
be just fine i promise i'll be cool like
now i just turn the journal i start all
over i'm cool because they're going to
fix that because i'll be down if i put
something 500 on the line and then that
joint just you break or whatever because
it was in rest nah nah not me
i think addict is right though what up
sir
like like what i saw
let me tell you something i'm sorry for
jumping in because i had i heard a whole
lot of cap a second ago it was like way
too much time i'm watching it
and it was way too much gap so what i
had to do is i had to say hey man
where's your fractions at
we getting it what you worried about it
for
we're talking about
and we and we're talking about doing the
fan base 30 you're gonna get a remaster
and a remake before you get your
fraction
and you might get a tv show before you
get to the factions but something that
you paid for that's supposed to be there
they're gonna make you pay double
they're gonna make you pay triple
they're gonna make you dip dip and
double dip then you did we get we dip
when you dick we get weaker we're all
different out here but we don't talk
about the sentences right let's do the
percentages how come 18
only finished uh what was that
horizontal
made bang a triple a banger a banger
king it take your old lady longer to
make sunday dinner take for people to be
uh
a game pass game that dropped day one
that's that's that's the cherry on top
you talking about we talk about triple a
see i can't let people mix apples and
oranges together and call it a pot it's
not going to happen today i just i was
just thinking a lot of cats and you know
i let the hell out you i can't let you
do yourself like that
i'm not allowing this i'm not allowing
this all right look we can talk about
factions because i got an issue with
that too we could definitely talk about
fashions let's fight parts part one
we're not doing that last what's
probably my second favorite game all the
time
no nothing should be separated from that
game dog and here's the here's the thing
factions ain't separated from it you can
get the remastered version right now for
like ten dollars if you if people want
to play that multiplayer that bad which
they don't know i want to play the new
one
but they really yeah i mean they're
remaking it they're remaking their joy
[Laughter]
i said this this can't go on like this
and you know i'm supposed to be on the
show my wife had card trouble so that
was getting done i said i got to get
gasses but bj says you know bite and
send the gas stimulus package i'm
sweating like a wild jamaican right now
it's on it's on
so y'all can y'all can clip this write
this down but i was not gonna let you
walk away with with one side going one
thing and they both doing us dirt yeah
yeah for sure oh no not for sure hey
listen listen the topic ain't the last
of us because when the topic is the last
of us what makes you think i'm not going
in when have i not done that
i need to know
you're right
the xbox in me had to defend that
the defense force had to come through
but
you know i love that i love the hell out
of attic and i do apologize i messed up
i was supposed to be there today i love
you guys i'm watching the show i'm about
to get back out i i just i just had to
come in here i just had to get at you
now you straight you stay
i'ma roast you when you leave okay you
know what that man
listen
it was a great day y'all i catch y'all
in the second piece all right
uh that's funny stuff man that's all
good nah nah when you know the last of
us pulling that bs i'm on them too yeah
i'm on them too but i'm gonna paint it
hey listen but i'm gonna keep a trail
with you though i'm definitely paying
that seventy dollars for less than
what's
hey listen i don't care
we all we look everybody got they
everybody got the one thing that they're
going to pay for last of us is going to
be that thing for me i'm not the last of
us yeah it's one of my favorite games of
all time and i know we talk about i know
we talking about halo so we got a pod so
my pony isn't right
we could talk about that real quick
explain to me why you want to spend 70
on a on a on on less of a game than you
got back then i mean you know the
visuals and the visuals in the game
players upgraded so it's not like i'm
just getting the same experience again
it's not like a rematch just didn't
realize that
you think tweaking the gameplay and
making the graphics look a little bit
better is worth the absence of half the
game
a little bit better a little bit better
that's that's cap when you're in at it
because you know you know that joint
looked phenomenal let's not can we let's
not do that y'all let's let's not do
that one let's not do that one and yeah
it's 70 dollars i mean for me i got a my
homegirl cassie she literally just did a
video on this she was like yo i'm simple
for 70 dollars and i got a big sign of
big sash that says you know hustle to
sim i don't care i don't care that's
just what i want that's what i want and
you're going to do what you do and yes
not only
and king said it earlier he was like yo
you going to pay for half the game yes
and i'm gonna pay sixty dollars again
for the factions version you know why
and i couldn't get into it while he was
there but i'm gonna say it now
y'all understand how many cheaters is in
the free to play i'm gonna take y'all
back and take it out back just a little
bit and then this game wasn't even free
to play but i'm gonna take y'all back to
pub g i remember when pub g first came
out on pc
people was running around with no heads
on their shoulders do y'all remember
that yes or no
yeah it was 30 dollars i paid for it i
had a good time when i played it people
was running around with their hands on
their shoulders that was my first time
because that was my first time getting
into pc gaming first time experienced
and all that cheating and stuff
don't make it free to play look nutty
dog gonna charge whatever they charge
for i don't think it's gonna be another
70 they'll probably charge 54. they'll
probably charge 44 who knows
i'm here for i'm gonna pay for the joint
man i'm going to look listen listen we
everybody got that moment
this is one of my this is this is the
dark moment for hustle i'm going to pay
for oh brother listen
listen bro listen
it's your money you can do what you want
to do with your money man i mean that's
flat out but um it got to be super
egregious to the point the way because
like naughty dog we could talk about
nothing though naughty dog got a history
of implementing like pay-to-win weapons
as long as they don't do that we
straight like i'm good like
i mean of course they can't can't do it
with this game ain't a multiplayer i
mean well all right
slow down
slow down look what do you mean they're
they're they're upcoming multiplayer i
mean i mean i mean the upcoming
multiplayer or whatever they decide to
call it plus i think it's pve too which
a lot of people i don't know if a lot of
people are not touching on it but i
think that's gonna be pve
cause by the way they made it sound it's
gonna be a service game like it's gonna
be a service game yeah i mean i'm not
sure so i mean so i'm a little divided
on that like i wouldn't
if it's a pve game and it has an actual
story on it i don't got a problem paying
for that i think it's gonna be like the
division of something probably
yo i paid ten dollars for the division
division two giant lit by the way i i
didn't think it was going to be that
good it's fun
anyone get these super chats added
before we go yeah yeah all right i was
letting you guys go man let you guys go
a little bit
so we got a five dollar subject from
phantom kraken uh
so 12 of what we need face of players to
know its overall completion example game
pass has 25 million players meaning that
12 of those players is 3 million him
cracking so what was found
what what he's saying hustle is he
saying take your take your percentage
and shove it because
three million people played it on game
pass and only and only 200 000 people
played it on playstation can i respond
to that yeah can i respond to that it
should have been 10 million carry on
thank you for your super chat we
appreciate your support
uh uh all right we'll we'll leave it at
that fan we'll leave you got two dollars
from lord metro
hustle is right 90 will never treat halo
of martial
nindy will never treat mario oh well
what is coming from a guy named lloyd
lord metro yeah i mean hey listen
shout out to lord metro yeah yeah he he
he'll be around this joint you know but
it's
i'm right i'm sorry i'm right and you
know what lord metroid and my
condolences to you or at least to samus
you're you're avi because the way they
do metroid boy yo listen those those
metroid games are cool they're not
necessarily for me but they cool dog and
like the fans don't even buy them joints
i don't i think metroid i think uh the
metroid drive i think that joint just
hit 3 million and that game has almost
been out of yeah like that's bad oh
that's that's not gonna be that's not
good like and that's that it's god awful
because they had the promotion and stuff
there too for that i saw a lot i saw a
lot of promotion for um metroid so
it's it's just a sad state of affairs
i'm not gonna hold you i wish um i wish
um
nintendo would sell the metroid
franchise to like playstation or xbox
because i know like i think the
coalition will run wild with metroid i
think because they'll get me interested
in that one but that's just me they i
say something right before you go at it
it seems like what like for whatever
reason
halo infinite the halo franchise
it gets scrutinized more
than any other franchise i can think of
right now um is it justified it is some
of it's justified maybe that's because
halo actually has like
halo gets criticized for stuff everyone
else should get criticized for
like battlefield people didn't expect a
single player to be good call of duty
people don't expect single player to be
good but for some reason halo and gears
people's like if both ain't fire the
game's trash
yeah yeah i mean see it's okay like your
shirt says they hate us
that logo should be 343 upon it or
master chief or something i mean what
are they like master chief but it's just
like i'm just i'm just noticing they
hate us because they ain't us
okay i didn't see the bottom of it but
no but i'm saying like you i don't know
if you guys noticed that it just seems
like
like
in the past nintendo will always get a
pass on anything right no matter what
they did
with the exception of maybe the wii u
nintendo always get a pass
it seems like
no matter what happens with halo
they get scrutinized no matter what like
i don't know maybe they
brought it upon themselves i'm not sure
but there's something to them like now
why are they getting criticized more
than anybody else like
battlefield 2042 got bashed right
then it's gonna get just stopped being
bashed then all the focus went back to
halo
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
like maybe it's me and my ex bot ways
but it just seemed like i'm just
noticing this getting hated on more than
anything else
yeah and it's just like at the end of
the day
i i'm never gonna tell you not to
criticize halo halo in 343 have showed
you that it needs to be criticized
but all i ask
is that everyone gets the same treatment
when
when last of us two
was announced
was last of us two was announced without
an entire component i felt like it was
talked about on a monday never brought
up on a friday i agree
but but when hagel if it doesn't do both
out the part
it's talked about in 2022 and we're
still talking about it next year in 2023
people never stop talking about it look
i will admit halo infinite and 343
they're constantly news for bad negative
stuff
but i don't think that shows
i don't think they i don't think the
criticism is justified look we could
criticize something i've always said if
you're going to talk about something
give them enough time to realistically
do something before you revisit the
subject
for instance microsoft has been spending
three to four years making these games
they bought in 2018. i feel like people
could talk about that because we're at
the point where it's like where are
these games i do feel like the industry
needs to be a little bit more open to
industry issues i feel like them trying
to be transparent never talk about look
fables in a good place we just
we've had to re-hire people we've had to
expand the studio that's why it's taking
longer i feel like people might get off
their back if they got info like that
but when you don't hear nothing and now
we're at this concept where if you don't
hear nothing it's the same as bad news
is it what's going on with it is it is
it in financial
is it financial hell is it in
development hell like what's going on
with this game why haven't we heard
about it compulsion haven't said nothing
in years and people are automatically
starting to assume the game isn't look
isn't doing good in development because
they're being so quiet
i do feel like the industry needs to get
to a point where they're more
transparent about
what goes on when making these games i
feel like they're too much and don't
talk
the pr is like
you know we could talk about this um can
we not talk about that can we like
it's just it's a little frustrating uh
let me get this super chat oh yeah you
know go ahead
this is a crazy name
let me make sure okay ten dollar
subscribe from smackda panda
yo
why do you guys think halo br coming in
2023 or 2024 and the campaign dlc is
coming in 25.
i heard 24 in those leaks
i don't know about the campaign or the
quarter or the br see yeah the campaign
um
now here the halo br that's probably
coming next year you'll probably see
that at e3 next year
and you'll probably see it launch in
like october september
so somewhere around that uh now as far
as the halo campaign
as long as it's
a lengthy
quality game full campaign yeah that's
fine i'm okay with this see the way i'm
looking at it is microsoft is going on
this direction where everything's going
to be of the the uh the halo infinity
brand
but when we release something it's going
to be a full-blown campaign it's going
to be like equivalent to buying halo 5
right or halo infinite from the start so
as long as it's that i don't even mind
paying them a full-blown retail thing
for a full-blown campaign right uh
because to me if you're gonna put it all
under one umbrella it makes the most
sense uh that's the only way i'm okay if
it's in 2024 2025
is if we get a good amount of content
now if it comes out like three hours
long yeah 40 bucks
[Music]
then at that point let's just
let's let's call let's call let's wrap
it up man that'd be some bs absolutely
that'd be two dollars to drive from
apollo cooper don't bash halo if you
don't like cash grabs if you like holy
craps yeah he's referring to um and
thank you thank you all for your
donations um he's referring to um and
i've been seeing these little stupid
articles go up is hey is that the last
of us remaking cash grab that just shut
up let me enjoy this can i do that
is it i don't think so i don't think so
the credit is like if
if they was remaking the remake then yes
then that would feel that way but like
if they if they're implementing new
new things like new gameplay elements
the way it's more verticality you can
you know do what you do and everything
in the last of us too if you're
implementing that and you're
implementing the new artificial
intelligence so on and so forth
of course with the graphics they're not
like yeah i feel like you earned the
money at that point because i feel like
it's gonna be a slightly different game
and i got a theory i don't know nobody
oh no no i'm not the snitch right i
don't know nobody but i think they're
going to implement stuff from uh the
story from uh halo 2 just to give abby's
people more of a backstory for the last
of us too yeah from the last first part
too yes sorry
yeah so
that's what i'm saying man i just i just
want the game to be better you got a two
dollar super from stream kingdom maybe
it's due to microsoft being too
transparent oh yeah i agree with you
bring up transparency yeah
go ahead go
well like you made a great point about
the studios being a little bit more
transparent but
it seems like
sometimes that's not the answer either
because when these studios are
transparent
there's blow there's there's
like blow back oh this is bs matt booty
said in 2020
first two years of the xbox series
generation
our games are going to be cross
generation
what
what
xbox what are y'all doing i didn't buy a
console to play last generation games
they got a lot of heat
right and
you see uh
it's just like sometimes
you want transparency
but looking from the studio standpoint
or xbox or a playstation standpoint like
yeah we tell them what's going on they
still gonna gonna talk trash so we might
as well not say nothing to them at this
time
which is unfortunate like
last uh okay
xbox
people said xbox will y'all show us some
stuff early because remember last
generation was like yo show us something
early but in reality they had nothing to
show cause like besides halo gears and
fours that they had no games in
development so when they started to have
games in development
they showed us state of k3 you know they
showed us a vow they showed us all of
these titles that's in development but
what do people say
all i saw was cgi trailers
so it's like
nobody can be i mean like people are
never happy
so it's like transparency is great yes
we would i would like transparency a
little more often
but at the end of the day
it here's what it is man
the the the sad part is it's just like
if they be too transparent
we gonna give them work if they're not
transparent enough yes
exactly you know that's why i feel like
you know if you're very open with what
happens in the industry
with what some of the troubles you're
having obviously the troubles that make
sense
then it's okay to talk about obviously
don't be telling us what you spent on
actually i think i think they should
tell us
the budgeting for some of these games to
give a realistic expectation when when
they want to raise prices to 70 dollars
they they should look this is what we
spent on
studio development 10 years ago this is
what we spend now this is why we're
raising it to 70 dollars a month uh a
game i feel like people would look at
that obviously you're not gonna make
everyone happy but i feel like if you're
being transparent with that kind of
information they're like okay i can
understand that then i still don't agree
with it but i can see
the cost has almost damn near quadrupled
since 10 years back and what's funny is
people want
people want microsoft to make these not
microsoft but anyone in general to make
these
aaa
gorgeous games these in-depth engines
but then when they raise the game by ten
dollars they lose their mind
i'm not saying that the ten dollars is
justified i can understand that
we have
probably quadrupled the amount of people
playing games in the past 20 30 years
absolutely easily
here's the thing
you're not
you're not guaranteed those sales
just because four
times the amount of people are playing
games and they was
10 15 years ago doesn't mean those
people are going to play your games a
lot of those people are playing fortnite
they're playing stuff for free why are
they going to spend 70 dollars on a game
why are they going to spend 60 dollars
on the game
it's like i said
i don't i don't like the 10 raise
but
we paid
60 dollars to the entire xbox one
generation
we paid 60 to the entire 360 generation
to my knowledge yep absolutely
do we really think we go another
generation without inflation catching up
to the gaming industry of course bro
that's how it is you know i mean that's
that's how it is man and i'm the type of
guy
um
he's listening paying seven dollars for
a game i don't care right if you feel
it's fine to pay seven dollars for a
game go right here i'll pay 70 for the
quarry right i don't think that's a 70
game but i really wanted to play it
i don't have problem with 70 games i
don't have problems with micro
transactions as long as it's not paid to
win
cosmetic micro transactions actually i'm
fine with that i disagree with you on
the cosmetic stuff
i don't
i don't like the way they're doing with
the cosmetics because i can understand
especially like in games like overwatch
where you pay for it
overwatch is a good example of how you
do something right because you can play
and get all those cosmetics
that's why that's the only thing i say i
don't want exclusive stuff tied down
behind something that you don't have
access to if you play the game a lot you
know what i'm saying like all right i
agree with that like destiny has a good
good way of doing it like sure if you
want stuff that's hot now you're gonna
have to pull out that wallet i've
literally seen people spend 200 and 10
minutes on destiny
but
if you want to wait and you're patient
you could probably get this stuff in the
next season when they put the stuff that
you want now when the new hot stuff
comes out
the stuff that you wanted last season's
in the bright dust shop okay and you can
buy that win game currency i'm fine with
that right right like if there's
something you
you want
i think you should have the chance to
earn it
like if you got a grind or like you just
gave a great example if that's the case
that's fine but this is me i just it
what people what other people do with
their money is their business i don't
care
if you want to decide like you said some
people on destiny spend 200 bucks in 10
minutes that's their money i don't care
so i'm a gamer and i love the industry i
love video games
and
we know these things cost money like the
last of us too absolute technical
masterpiece of the game
you know that game was hella expensive
to make
you know that game was extremely
expensive to make
from the graphics to to to the little
small stuff the game was
a technical masterpiece
i'm sure that game costed the hundreds
of millions of dollars
millions of dollars to make so nowadays
we got people wanting these
aaa
extremely expensive games to be made in
two years
to to have
no monster like no micro transactions no
multiplayer and then the game goes to
sell 10 million out of 120 million
consoles or sold fan base and you guys
wonder why jim ryan's like i might have
put some of these damn games on pc
all of them really
because they're not you know doing what
they need these games to do only
nintendo can continue to make the same
games that they've made for years
and they'll sell 40 million 35 million
but if you look at mario kart the budget
isn't out of the last of us
no so
my point is
us as gamers we see what's going on
we see how these games are super
expensive to make and we love them
so the game go up to 70 okay okay we can
cry complain about it but we're still
going to pay for it
household motivators say i am paying
seventy dollars for the last bus part
one remake i don't give a damn when
nobody says and i respect that
hold up real quick what why don't you
tell people you spent on these 30 year
old games
i did i did y'all like spend 200 on this
oh damn what's [ __ ] like no wonder y'all
got a problem paying seven dollars
you're not like that that that 70 and
when i see people talk about that 70
argument first of all
i never really paid well well i pay less
than 70 dollars for games but like the
super nintendo games that i used to
enjoy back in the day oh yeah those are
like 70 dollars bro 78 yeah it's gone
so now absolutely bro
uh do i got oh yeah one the other wild
hey your hustle i need to be shot for i
spent i spent 100 for this what's up hey
let me tell you a quick story about
super nintendo i remember going to funko
land you know which of course gamestop
now i remember going there and buying
that dinosaur fighting game primal rape
and i remember being blown away
when the guy told me
79.99
i said what
this game cost 79.99 and this was back
in mid 90s bro maybe 95
94
i said no i'm not buying this game for
eight nights
that's one of the reasons the gaming
market almost crashed
super dip super nintendo n64 games the
prices of those games man oh my god
insane boy yeah
i got a um a super nintendo link to the
past back there in my chores
really
okay
so we got a two dollar spec from flame
real quick uh values on the eye of the
beholder and fan boys and uh put the put
the crest in the chat man for a big
cloud gaming has joined the realm of the
lord brown bronze
mm-hmm y'all make sure y'all check the
rgt podcast
i'm not sure when but apparently they
have a very special guest who will be uh
making his debut there making their
debut there pardon me so what was you
saying dirk
no i was just saying that you know
somebody my age that has lived through
every console generation to see these
things us you know like people crying
and complaining about this man we was
like like hustle said we were spending
70 dollars for super nintendo in 64
games man if you want to spend 70
dollars for a game that's your
prerogative yes we might talk trash oh
yeah they took out the multiplayer
if you feel like it's justifiable to to
pay seventy dollars for
fine man that's your money i don't care
but i'm just saying
we can't keep on complaining about the
price of stuff going up
but we keep on wanting these high
quality games these high quality games
cost money
they cost money man so we can't want the
last of us 3 to be a 500 million dollar
game
and don't want any micro transactions no
multiplayer and they want the game
developed in two and a half years this
is not reality nowadays man these games
cost money because they take take take a
lot of money to make
all right so um
let's go ahead and uh you know
restructure we kind of went off track
though but it's okay it's a good
conversation
uh let let's roll this back and talk
about red fall uh you know
i
have made my statements very public
about red fall multiple times um i did
make a video
uh shout out uh you know definitely go
over there watch that after the show if
you want it's pretty much like stating
my opinion on the new update so there
was
some new updates that miranda said you
know first off before we go into like
the full-blown thing i want to get you
guys a general opinion right now
on red falls so we'll start with uh dirt
you know i noticed you you're a big
advocate for for red fall what's your
opinion on the game right now i think it
looks great uh first off i love arcane
games i love them i love the dishonored
games one and two i also love the dlc
um i love pray
so when you love a studio you're
interested in their next project i
didn't play def loop um i was gonna get
it for the ps5 i just might as well wait
for it to come to xbox at this point
because i prefer achievements over
trophies that's just me um so i'm
waiting for it to come to xbox but uh
yeah i think the game looks great and
excuse me
in my opinion i always start the game
was
a single player game
with multiplayer
i never thought it was going to be a
co-op
uh like a like a game that was built
from the ground up being a co-op game
because that's really not arcane's mo
there are great single-player uh uh
stories uh great single-player games
that they made in the past so yes
rare fall looks incredible to me and
after showcase uh last month you know
the first game they show was railfar and
i was like yes
yes i can't wait for the game so
and and it seems like um some of the
developers they confirmed my
my thoughts that it's a single player
game you know like you would get that
that classic arcane single-player game
feel
just what you can do with your friends
also i'm gonna go solo like when the
game comes out i'm going fully solo i'ma
treat it like an arcane game you know
yeah i think the game was great though
man it looks great
all right what about you hustle you know
how's your feelings you don't really get
your thought process too much on
something like
something like
red fall you know i'm kind of curious
what your opinion is on it
yeah indifferent and different not good
not bad it's cool like when the last
time we saw it it was um
it definitely looked better than the
alpha footage that we saw which you know
as it should um
i'm cool on that i mean i don't
particularly want to see more like what
was the other one back for blood like
those types of games
back from love cheeks i don't want to
say see i don't want to see i don't well
hell if i sound like a hypocrite i sound
like a hypocrite because i don't want
the last of us uh
the new whatever that multiplayer is
i don't want the new multiplayer to be
like that i kind of want it to be at
some thing but if you know arcane has
something special and they can turn
a pve type of co-op thing into something
you know amazing and something
phenomenal in terms of storytelling and
i saw it you gamepl when you tweeted it
out attic i saw the thing i said we're
ready for i look i just want to say i'm
glad dirty is here you know what i mean
like
i'm glad you're here brother i'm i'm
extremely glad you're here because it's
saying
you're not the same for me it's just
ain't for me it's just thing hey thing
of mine man it's definitely not not a
thing of mine um
uh well when is the schedule to come out
did they say it's supposed to be next
year right it does yeah early next year
yeah but you have no date yet it'll be
before e3 next year yeah yeah cause it
was a part of that the e3 conference too
all right
i hope i hope it turns out well for the
people who who look forward to that um
i really hope if it does turn out well i
hope it support it because you know with
games like that you kind of got to kind
of keep it going um do you think that
there's anything missing from what we
saw so far that we maybe maybe we're not
privy to like is there any mode that you
would like to see in it
um
i would like to
hear more about the story
um you know we know basic stuff about
the story
but as far as modes i i'm not sure what
modes they would have inside story and
co-op will like happen in this co-op
campaign
i'm not sure but um
yeah i would like to know more about you
know like the character's backstory and
i'm sure we'll learn that more over time
well you know some of the the
occupations i know the black girl she's
a student i believe and some other stuff
uh but yeah i mean it's definitely it's
definitely interesting i would like to
see what the banter is between the
characters you know
really good banter
death luke like
julian like they had such iconic banter
like every time he started a loop like
they okay you could tell like she's so
cocky at the beginning
she she she know she always remembers
what happens it's cold that usually
always forgets
and
you could tell the farther co gets
the dynamic switches
it's
now julian she's the one flipping out
cole is the one that's cocky
and then what i love he's like you know
i'ma find you i'ma get you yeah it's
like it's just a matter
yeah baby don't be a job turkey i'm
gonna find you oh my god
i like to i like the the banter because
the banter was funny
that's the i would like that kind of
banter with these characters like give
them personality you know like make it
seem like they know each other
yeah exactly the person that i love
hey
like i made fun of every black guy in
the video game sounds like that right
hey hey you job turkey hey mama come
over here baby who am you
you was fine as wine mama
these black toys like that black puss
who am you
come on
all black guys don't sound like that
they say every game the black ass song
what was that final fantasy uh was that
uh seven remake
yeah
you know what's funny though like i know
come on clouds let's go i know a lot of
people didn't like barrett's voice yeah
but that's how i pictured him talking
because he's always aggressive
he's always like mr t
yeah that and you know if you look at
him he kind of looks like mr t a little
bit so it's like i that's that's kind of
i expected his persona because people
was like well he talks like an angry
person and i'm like
he's angry that's literally what baird
is
he's mad
he's got a best friend he's got a best
friend that's missing uh the other one
because they got pretty much like he he
was falling off like a cliff in the
original final fantasy uh spoiler alert
five four three two one uh he was
falling off like a little cliff in the
original final fantasy and
uh
bear grabbed him and someone shot
both someone shot his hand
so went through his hand and his friend
i think it's the opposite hand uh yeah
dying and what happened is that went
through his hand and went through the
other dude's other hand
wow okay hey man your memory of video
game stories is very good because
there's like you're talking about fable
too i finished fable too i don't
remember none of that i remember the 10
year thing that's all i remember your
memory is very good with that i remember
specific stuff it's like i said like i
could have swore it was a it was a kid i
don't know why
uh i could have maybe maybe kids were
there and that's i'm getting the yeah
but i i haven't played final uh fable 2
probably in 15 years
you know because fable one is my
favorite i usually go back to that to
play it uh you know final fantasy vii
that's the black kyle final fifth seven
remake fable toe was pretty dark yeah it
was a pretty dark game uh you know let's
go ahead and move on to um to god of war
releasing
and 20.
i mean so first off uh we're not
starting with hustle because i already
know i'm not gonna go
uh we're gonna start with dirt
yes yes so i want your general
impressions let's not go deep into it
yet about
what where were you
and
what was your first reaction when you
finally
saw that release day november
the 9th
i was at work and i just looked at my
phone so well it's no surprise because i
maybe asked ask me a couple weeks ago or
no like last show we did on uh like
sunday a couple weeks ago we asked me
uh i said yeah i believe it's coming out
in 2022 because this is like
corey barlock was way too active on
twitter he was talking a lot like that
like right right right he was talking a
lot though this game is definitely
coming out in 2022. and to be honest you
know everybody know i bleed green i'm
team xbox but the like the reason i
hopped on the chance to get my ps5 now
was because god will ragnar i love the
franchise god of war 2018 was one of my
favorite games
um i thought it was an incredible game
last generation the witcher 3 and god of
war 2018 was my favorite games right
there neck and neck i i might get a
witch or a slight knife but the god of
war was right there so yeah i'm actually
hyped um for the game
i'm looking forward to the game um i did
want to talk a little trash
but you know i can't
i can't talk trash not because it's
coming out this year but yeah i think
it's good that it's coming out man so
yeah um
i think that the biggest thing when it
comes to uh god of war is that we get
hustle's opinion on it so oh man uh you
know i i know how so i i know you was he
was hardcore in this god of war streets
man anything blew you with it man you
with it so
wha wha what's your opinion on it man
where were you what was your thought
process
i do believe i was at work when what
they didn't come out on
i might have been sitting at home i'm
not exactly sure but i mean i told y'all
a long time ago the joint was dropping
this year we didn't saw we didn't saw
way way too much we didn't sell way too
much information about this game
to afford not to come out we we saw
corey barlog out there tweeting you know
for accessibility day which was cool
like you know i mean they were showing a
whole lot then
corey ballard started tweeting you know
with dinner about his wife and they was
like yo we want to hear about the game
cause like but yo with every from
february i think i may have said this
here you know what's happening on the
rgt podcast y'all make sure y'all check
out the homie big club let me check that
podcast so pretty much since february
probably before that too but since
february we've heard something at least
one good thing about that game each and
every month um we've heard some bad
things too about terms of harassment i'm
not condoning that of course we ain't
moving like that
but
i'm gonna lie everything's a roll out
i've said that on here before too
yeah i got it from joe budden but he's
right everything is a roller all that's
promotion dawg every little thing all
the little seeds little gum drops
whatever all that's promotion i knew
that dream was i knew it was coming out
this year because if it wasn't coming
out this year or they didn't know they
would and corey barlow's not even
directing this game but that would have
been on his neck
then that show would have fell on on him
at that point because the way that man
been tweeting about
everything
they would have been on them but not now
but i know it was coming because we saw
we saw entirely too much um
that is um the main reason why i'm
buying all the og god awards because i
want to see what the differences are
aside from the fixed camera angles i
want to see if the story is a little
different a lot of people say kratos
wants solved i'm finna see for myself so
i'm copying all the god of wars i'm
trying to run through them all probably
starting in august so good little promo
for me cause i was right now i feel like
i deserve this i needed
i just need to let y'all know
this will be knowing sometimes see i
don't know everything i don't know
anything but i'll be knowing some of the
things you got just follow me up just
follow me and
everybody's gonna be fine listen addict
i don't know if you're getting that game
day one i'm gonna try again today one or
something i can beat um gotta work 2018
before i drop but i'm a cop to join day
one man i'm a cop of day one oh man i
forgot you didn't finish the uh the 2018
one nope i'm running through it though
i'll make sure i run through it back i
got to run through that thing i got the
right i got to do it now all right it's
a look
god award i'm happy this happened man
because man it's
it's it's been rough out here this see
you here like they ain't really much to
play
now obviously there's stuff that you
could play and you know people get onto
me when i say that it's like look like
i'm not talking about the stuff i always
play i'm not talking about the 18th time
i played fable anniversary or the 3
000th hour i have in destiny 2 or you
know the the the indie games that i play
for a couple days i'm talking about that
game
that you can't sleep the night before it
comes out like that that's the game i'm
talking about and god where is that like
look i got my own personal things about
that i might do an attic spotlight on it
in the future you know we might do one
see if you guys want to be part of it
you know where we'll talk about our
expectations with god of war
and you know exactly how you you want to
play i'm just i'm curious how they
handle so many variables
of god of war you got freya still alive
you got odin and thor and i'm assuming
thor gonna die early in the game so they
can get his hammer uh because i'm pretty
sure he's going to use that i mean uh
kratos at this point he's he used the
others the axis technically thor's two
in in mythology so one would think he's
gonna get this hammer so
i'm curious how they handle all of that
and tell it
all in one story
hey addict real quick um
apparently the game is going to be
released on odin's day or something like
that now i'm not too familiar what that
means
but apparently odin has a big part in
his game and it's going to be released
on his day or whatever it is you know a
lot of people i saw online too a lot of
like there are certain symbols on the
top of that hammer or axe or whatever it
is
there are certain symbols and people are
like unlocking like what those symbols
mean
apparently this game is going to go to
egypt because this is the last game and
um you know ragnarok is it's just a big
winner thing and it's going to be the
last game in this
portion of what god of war is
and um
i mean i'm here for it man i'm here for
i'm i'm ready to get that whole entire
story but apparently
because it's speculated that kratos may
die
nobody know
however because if you beat the first
game you saw the ending of it nobody
really know
um
shout out to chris righteous he had
actually mentioned like this like time
travel with this whole series so that's
and that's actually where maybe go back
and get the first game so i kind of just
want to um unravel all that good stuff
it's cool man it's cool that you know
playstation you know save the day
um you know they say today they say that
is it because nothing was really uh
aside from what starfield nothing was
dropping in what november right that
like call of duty if you play call of
duty yeah call of duty yeah yeah so that
was really that was really dropping man
i mean you know and apparently from what
i understand this game is going to be
really long which which that doesn't
surprise me at all because if you're
rapping wrapping up a saga
i mean you know you normally do it in
three games but if you're doing it in
two so
one game is 20 hours and the other one
might be 40 who knows who knows so
speculation yes
go ahead and keep talking while i set up
a poll real quick
all right well
i i kind of want to you know ask you
dirk because like i think you're a tad
bit more familiar with the franchise
than myself
is there anything that you would like to
see in terms of boss fights
um
well we already saw from the preview
that is definitely going to be a
thorough boss fight oh for sure because
i'm going to tell you the stranger that
was an incredible boss well well like
the first one
well like you know that both was cool
but the first one was just incredible
like he just went to his door you know
like what's up thought like get off my
the porch man
leave my home
that was this fire man so yeah i'm
definitely looking forward to um thor
there was some big
i don't know what it was some big thing
in the in the latest trailer i know with
cgi i don't know if that's going to be
in the game even though the latest
trailer was cgi uh but
it's like man
i'm look i'm definitely looking forward
to it because even with the 2018 game
they had that huge monster in the like
in the trailer oh you no that's yo
that's loki's son apparently i didn't
know that i did not know that but
apparently that's you talking about the
there's a monster that's that huge
monster yeah but only loki can
understand it apparently in the actual
mythology of it that's yeah
the snake yeah yeah it's his son too
yeah like you know you know like before
you played the game you thought that was
a boss but obviously you know he's he's
not
but uh you know so yeah i'm definitely
looking forward to the game man big big
fan
um got a two dollars from david ramos i
believe odin's day is a wednesday so
yeah
yeah it is a wednesday yeah i'm excited
i feel like god of war is going to be a
phenomenal game i don't know if it's
going to be elden ring for game of the
year which you know i say we got about
10 minutes before i tie this podcast up
what do you guys think
the odds of god of war
coming in there
and tripping eldon ring like imagine you
know i want everybody in the chat to
close your eyes and imagine
you you're walking up
the stairs to get your high school
diploma man just you're walking up it
and then you get that that dude that you
never like he just trips you and he
takes your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what are the odds of that happening to
elden ring where he's walking up the
stairs and god of war grabs him by both
his legs and just yanks him off the
stage and they go get that that degree
we'll start with with uh dirt first hey
you know what i i gotta be honest
i'm not really a ld ring fan
i tried the game uh i bought the game
but i will tell you this
the hype surrounding eldering was
incredible
it was just so much hype surrounding
this game like
wow
like people knew the game was coming it
came out and everybody was just loving
it playing the game there was so much
hype me a person that don't really care
for from software style games
i bought it it's like damn my mind as
well try it everybody's saying how
incredible the game was you know the
meta critic was extremely high
um i don't know man god of war
it definitely has a chance but i just
don't know it seemed like the hype for
that game elder wing
i don't think can be surpassed
this year i just don't see it man um
i'm sure god of war ragnarok will be
fine it will be dope it would be a
highly rated game
for something about the other ring and
the the hype surrounding that game i
don't i don't know if any game can take
it down i don't think i don't want to
take it down this year
what about you hustle well i disagree
of course you do no no no no no let me
let me finish we've seen two things on
two parallels in terms of the game
awards this year right we saw a god of
war
and and not it's not that the game
wasn't anticipated that year we we saw
god of war take home the big war when i
think it was devastating that was kind
of winning a bunch of other red dead
redemption too redemption there we go
red that redemption my fault i got the
games mixed up we saw red dead
redemption 2 take home a lot of awards
but not the big one
then i think it was the next [ __ ] we saw
second row
from from software we saw a second row
come out what early that year and like i
think it was february 2 as a matter of
fact no i think i think cycle came out
2017. didn't it well okay well
regardless regardless we saw sakura take
home no no no that came out 2019. i'm
sorry
you're throwing me off there hold on no
no no no one like game of the year in
2019. that's what i'm getting that's
what i'm getting at yeah we saw we saw
we saw a game on sakura you know win
game it again yeah yeah so
no it's all good because here's where
i'm going with it it's going to be the
brawl for it all it's going to be the
clash of the titans and i think god of
war is going if if that in that hit the
way it's supposed to hit if the story
gonna hit the way it's supposed to hit
because y'all know why thor showed up at
uh kratos in the treasures door right
y'all do know see i didn't play the game
but what i do know is they they killed
the
they killed those sons they they bought
it they caught a couple bodies they
caught a couple they were trying to get
in the trays his head and all that and
they caught a couple bodies um
that's what i thought was there
a lot of people are debating whether
that boss fight is going to happen in
the beginning i would say yes only
because at the end of the game
they tell you go back home once you go
back home a little time has passed
there's no one outside yeah yeah
everybody take the long sleeve the long
nap everybody take the long nap he wake
up
we see though there he
whip his little
robe or whatever back whip his what whip
is what
[Music]
you know it's wild hustle wants another
man to whip his
oh man i am just stating the facts
that's all i'm saying no but i think
that i think i i think that boss fight
happens in the very and i know we're
talking about that but i think that boss
fight happens in the very beginning and
either he dips or he runs away because i
don't i can't there's i can't imagine
him dying in the beginning like that
like because that's like a tutorial boss
fight because that's almost something in
the very beginning unless they do a
flashback while you sleep with something
like that
like that's the thought of being in
there that's that's kind of like a big
thing
i don't know they they you know um
almost said sony center almost another
dog someone said the monica they got a
way around that if they really want to
play play that shout out the uh weapon
wizards listen to the weapon will
a lot of people think it's going to take
place in the first hour i'm one of those
people if it's any if it's going to be
at the direct continuation right after
that story after you go home and go
outside and you see throw it in and all
that with the lightning and such
yeah and not only um i think one of
y'all mentioned it yeah um
um a tray is probably cam wielded so
cradles will wield that sword it
actually comes with the um
is it got me well i i it's a word to
start with a j that i cannot pronounce
the other part of me but it comes with
that special edition the hammer comes
with a special edition and real quick
but real quick before y'all go
i i hate when when different companies
do this i hate it when call of duty had
did this one year they give you like a
collector's edition with no disc
like bro oh hold on
hold on
hey can i kind of defend them this time
okay i'm about to defend the playstation
i can't believe this i'm about to defend
playstation i can't believe this but it
makes sense because
they have a all digital console
hey roller because they got a flashlight
yeah they yes of course they have the
physical console which the digital code
works on
but they can't have a physical
game now because what if a
digital ps5 owner buys the collector's
edition they can't play the game
if it was physical
now you see what i'm saying no you okay
well i tell you what if that's the case
they need to do what these blu-rays are
doing and give you a physical copy and
then you know they can do that
now they can do that yeah if you talking
like that then do that then yeah yeah
yeah
they can do that
so you said you ain't buying by my
theory huh man i wouldn't i i i will
never be cool with no game that being in
the car like y'all bro i'm party paying
you the money like yeah if i want the
little trinkets and stuff cool fine okay
you give me those but you give me the
game too i'm paying for that too i don't
care if it's two hundred dollars give me
my break get my game dog get my game i
don't want no no no no give me my
physical
yo i see what you're saying it's just
listen if it didn't come with a steel
case or something then you might have a
point then i get it they're like all
right i guess you can i see what you're
saying i'll see what you're saying but
this is why i think they couldn't really
i mean but but you understand what i'm
saying though right
it's like dirt i see what you're saying
but it don't make sense
i see what you're saying but what you're
saying is what you want not what you
know what's the right thing to do i'm
saying it should be dog like that's yo
what you got a case in there with no
game
it's wow
listen that's that's like the restaurant
stuff that i'll be going through like if
i got a game with no case i can buy a
case and the magic would sim separate by
itself i think i'm talking about
righteous prices but you know nothing i
digress what's up man it's like i said i
think the reason they do that is because
digital is just so high now where
i think a lot of like collectors
they'd rat like they'd rather
that's just me if you buy collectors you
want collector things
so i think
they would rather sacrifice the game
that they're probably gonna buy
digitally anyway
and get more and get that value
returned on like maybe the statue would
you rather a more up-to-date looking
statue because they don't have to
accommodate for that 70 that goes into
that collector's edition to get a better
statue or would you rather that game and
have a way worse statue go
hustle people want both of them to be on
point i want the high value statue and
the game like what are we doing and like
yo listen king i don't know what that is
what [ __ ] g said
what's up like pierce of big g said like
you gotta buy two copies because you
want the physical game he'll buy the
collector's dish and you buy a physical
guy that's wild to me like yo you
supposed you supposed to include it
there but like if it were me honestly yo
you include that game uh king shout out
to king who's supposed to be here today
he got them two thousand dollar statues
and all that first of all
i never go there i never take it there
because that that's just not me this is
way too much for my blood let me be the
first to tell you
bro with them statues like those are
real statues so if i'm paying for
something like that
and also if we doing that if we're doing
that without the game in the case don't
make that limited edition or whatever
don't make it so limited there don't
don't make that joint limited whatsoever
you need to make that joint mass if
that's the case if it ain't coming with
the game
so you think oh ho ho
you need to make more of them there
that's how i feel hold up look
you think the reason
that there's limitations on the game on
these collectors is because of the game
it's because of the product that's in
the collectors that has nothing to do
with the game well they need to make
more products they probably got
millions of those games just laying
around they could put in that that has
nothing if anything taking the game out
and they could actually put more money
into the collectors will get will let
you have more of the collector stuff
because they're not worrying about
accommodating for that 70 dollars that
you that's in there because i mean look
at it from
price point what
collectors usually what 200 to 500
around that price range okay
uh
so let's say it's 200 250
put that game in there the cost of the
stuff they put in that
in that bundle in that collectors is
gonna have to exceed like 180 bucks now
would you not rather
[Laughter]
okay all right all right i gotta keep
what you guys have a selfish hobby man
you know you know why don't dog cause
it's
it's trinkets it's knickknacks it's cool
to have it's cool to like
give a dog
yeah it's cool it's cool to have him put
up on the shelf and like hey look at my
little that's cool yo put a game in
there though like it's two hundred
dollars
if they get they give you a digital code
the game is there oh you tell me
you got a spellbook with no game in it
you know like that that's that that to
me is like yo if the steelbook wasn't
there you want to do all that now what
happens if
okay
yeah go ahead
this hammer
the hammer they gonna give you those god
of war collectors
if they put the actual game in there it
goes from a hammer to like the map of
ragnarok or whatever it is which one you
want
yo i want to know where the game is i'm
sorry what you want me to say like it's
nothing listen listen there's nothing
wrong with what you're saying but just
my thought process
could can you spit can you imagine
spending two hundred dollars
on something without the main thing that
you brought in but what what without
okay
if you buy a collector's edition like
the main thing is the game
yes
no that's that was nothing
so hold up hold up hold up hold up hold
up so if they gave you a collector's
edition and they told you week or so you
[ __ ] in this collector's position until
you pick it up but you're gonna have a
still game with a still a still case
with a game in it you're gonna buy it
hustle we can't change
oh now we don't wanna we can't change
that narrative you know why we can't
change that narrative if this game
didn't come with a still book i wouldn't
be saying now but but but why why does
it why does it matter
what else is in it if they get the game
you only buy for the game also why is it
there why why is it why why
why is it still a book series so you
know what
dirt he ain't going to use anything else
in that in that collection should be
that hammer hustle send me that ham hey
i give you the whole joint look because
you know what it's going to do it's
going to sit up that joint and then
collect dust all right
i'm cool like first of all first of all
and i used to buy collector's editions
and all that that's cool if you
you're a fanatic like that that's cool
that's fine that's that's dandy i think
what they offer in this collector's
edition it's very good just put the game
with the joint don't put
don't you dare tease me and then put the
book put the still book there
don't put the case in the joint are you
okay also
no no because it's not because it's
[ __ ] don't put the case in the joint
without having the game in it though
a physical game what what you got the
case there for
why is the case there if ain't no game
there
uh
we know what the ham is there we know
that little terry cloth or whatever we
know what that map is there we know why
everything else is in the joint we know
why that's dead why wha why why would
you all right we're we're good that's
all that's all we got we're gonna agree
oh my god anyone have any last thoughts
on god award
nope i look forward to the game i look
forward to the game all right so you
know we're gonna go ahead and uh close
this show i do got some um
some thought process i want to do for
the show
so you don't have to see what we uh
think about there uh the lords will be
having a community week this saturday
hopefully i'm not gonna confirm anything
or deny anything
right now it's happening saturday
but i can't promise anything because
anything can always change so look out
for that uh probably i'm gonna i'm gonna
try to get we'll probably play two two
and a half hours i'm gonna try to sneak
in two games
uh i want to play overcooked i feel like
the lord's playing overcooked would be
crazy it will be it will and uh they
want to probably play teenage mutant
ninja turtles which i'm completely fall
guys that'd be fun
yeah we can play fall guys i think
that's actually one of the games but you
know i appreciate everyone coming
through it was a good show hustle where
can the people find you at never mind
dirt where can they find you
there we go that's why no go go i'm
joking
[ __ ] you're right you're right
oh my god it's a joke where can they
find you at hustle no um twitch twitter
and youtube um
hustler motivate listen listen sunday
because i got the video i just need to
finish editing it i probably won't do it
today i'll do it tomorrow um i got a
retro games pickup so i pretty much got
that and that's
set up for sunday
i've been lacking on the uploads only
because i've been dealing with like the
work thing but none of them officially a
new hire at another place
weight off my shoulder and i'm back um
take me to um wait wait wait not take me
join me there we go join me as i play uh
nba street volume two
grand theft auto san andreas on twitch
and i will have those retrospectives the
retrospective is going to take a while
but i'm gonna run through them games and
that's what we're gonna be playing on
twitch um catch me every wednesday catch
me on twitter as well i know somebody
follow me early again i appreciate you
uh you know for my my gaming outtakes so
you know some of those i had to take
some of those you know not so high techs
but i enjoyed the show as always at it
it's just cool like i always have fun
when i'm here
yeah i appreciate it and
dart where can they find you at man what
you got going on
uh well i don't have much going on this
week
i want to do a video man but there's
nothing to talk about right now i
thought about doing a
fanboy video about the tools you know
the you know xboxes you know like
they've been winning these like digital
foundry comparison videos lately i
wanted to talk about that but uh uh yeah
so i got nothing going i'm just gonna
play some games this week uh yo check
this out monday
on dirt griggity uh youtube channel
weebly green podcast 6 30 p.m eastern
standard time we got a special guest
all right here we go
oh okay i was like you're kind of
confused like what are we now are we
saying that now you say it on twitter
like yeah i know i just said now but i
do it on twitter also yeah it was a
little ad is going to be a guest and um
you know over there we're we're just
unfiltered we're going to have a good
time man yeah
they're exact words
their exact words was we want the loose
addict we don't want the
the button up t-shirt at it
you know
like you don't have to be the pg-13 at
it you can be it's
do your thing we have good good time so
stop by on monday on my channel
uh 6 30 p.m eastern standard time yeah
we're gonna have fun man
hey um
one more thing before we go
um typically you know i noticed that
you've done this on ilp and so i want to
like take a note to what you're doing
there um when you see a streamer or
up-and-coming streamers or different
podcasts that you like and that you
enjoy that you love to listen to can i
just take the time to promote a level
one gamer
yeah
i'm not sure why but they are live right
now so listen y'all i want all of y'all
to go over the um
level one game and i'm gonna put the
chat i'm gonna put they join the chat
right now y'all go over there y'all
typing uh he sent you no say addict show
central there we go tell them that the
attic show central man y'all go y'all go
pull up on my people man the extremely
great podcast double xp podcast dirk
once again man thank you for joining us
man you damn a member of the family at
this point it'd be cool if you'd be a
permanent member over this joy i mean
it'd be cool for me yeah
yeah yeah it's cool man
sometimes i'll be having to rush home on
wednesday so you like to make the five
o'clock uh
ain't no thing but no no but it's always
always great having you around man and
um who's another honorary member who um
we'll be starting playing xbox on
mondays in august i do believe i'm i'm
starting to starting all remember so
y'all make sure i go support this move
as well um
thank you for coming here i appreciate
you man thank you bro i appreciate you
guys quick question i
i don't
because i've been looking to
um
apparently you you're able to
buy memberships on iop
on youtube yeah how exactly does that
work do you have to be a member to buy
it first or
i don't know that's a good question tell
me okay members
uh obviously don't gift chat uh
memberships unless you absolutely want
to but uh members check and see if it
gives you the option to buy uh to gift
memberships i just wanna know how it
works i've never it doesn't give
the iop account i can't see that
i'm kind of curious that that's how that
works
so
if you remember
go to i don't even know how you gift it
like that that youtube does a really bad
job at snap at stilling
uh at stealing features from other
platforms but don't explain how to use
them
i don't know brother i mean i'm trying
to figure it out myself
i'm going to see perks right now it
doesn't see it doesn't really you see it
doesn't say because i'm under the
membership perk right now
yeah it doesn't say
it doesn't it is what it is i'm not
really well yeah go go over there to a
level one gaming man
tell at the the attic show sent you man
the attic show sent you uh i i want to
see that in the chat i'm gonna look at
that chat and look at the 162 people in
here i'm gonna stalk that chat man i
want to see it say the attic show since
you definitely uh sub to dirk griggity
for uh me to come on there monday uh
that should be interesting i ain't been
on a podcast like that in a while uh so
that that's gonna be an interesting time
uh but definitely go over there
attic hit the dots
what dots
i don't know what he means
i don't know w we'll figure that out
later but appreciate ever coming through
i'm gonna go and close the show up until
next week probably have king all next
week because uh he had some car issue
stuff this is my pr fault probably i
should have probably uh you know hit him
up but i ended up like an hour before
the podcast like yo you still coming on
because i was asleep but i appreciate
the service to sleep man because you
asked me to come on this morning and i
replied like two minutes after you and
you never you said you thought i didn't
reply
yeah you see i work graveyard shift i
worked 12 days in the morning so i
literally got home
put up the stream and then i went to bed
yeah
hit the dots under memberships then it's
the gifting settings oh okay all right
all right but i appreciate every coming
through we're going to end the stream
peace